thì Đợi mình
tí mình sẽ vào lại cái link ở
bên bên
kia để làm cái bài
nghiệm th ra là kinh nghiệm thực tế của
mình chức là hơn Mới một năm thôi
Kiểu chủ yếu là tự làm à dự án chứ không
có nm kinh nghiệm thực tế
lắm hò Nguyễn ơ ơ ơ Bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
nó bảo là cái này
sẽ trên certificate à Long Nguyễn
Nguyễn Nam đúng
[âm nhạc]
end web backend developer
ờ tôi run lắm rồi Cái này 60 phút 60
phút Chắc không sao đâu Tôi chưa xem
trước đề cũng không biết được đề nó sẽ
như th nào đề bằng tiếng Anh Chắc chắn
rồi nhưng mà chắc là ờ
chắc là tôi hiểu được đề là tôi không
biết được có tab ra để tra Google được
không thôi hi vọng là tra được Tôi không
nhớ được C Pháp vào lắm Tôi không tự tin
khoản này lắm đâu Ừ chắc là chứng chỉ
này chắc là chứng chỉ này chắc là bên
này cấp chứ không phải là kiểu dạng là
chứng chỉ gì gì đó tôi cũng từng thi
chứng chỉ ở
bên School với Len rồi nhưng mà SQL Hình
như tôi chưa chưa thi Nói chung là chưa
biết
thêm chữ advan chắc là nó sẽ khó hơn so
với wp school nữ cả
len nhưng mà cứ thử đã mấy ông Chắc là
ngồi đọc câu hỏi cùng tôi xong rồi thực
ra không cần nhắc tôi đâu Chắc là tôi sẽ
tự làm nh mấy ông đọc câu hỏi cùng tôi
để mà à chúng ta tí Giả sử không làm
được
thì tí mình khi mà quá thời gian chung
hết giờ thì mình cũng sẽ chữa lại giả sử
Nếu không nào kịp đúng không ạ thừ
nhỉ hacker rank bình thường đã khó rồi
ôi còn chưa thử Bình thường tôi đã chơi
Advance rồi hay tôi thử cái bình thường
chứ
basic bởi vì cái này nó còn liên quan
thuật toán này nghe Sậu quá B
notion là là chuẩn hóa này Uầy trên này
sợ nhỉ
Ồ hấp dẫn hấp dẫn xem nhá chọn cái easy
rồi chơi trước
Ờ thử cái Hot cái hot
đúng
này
inter Internet là gì
nhỉ
Đây Joy Union suby cái này tôi hiểu Còn
cái này là gì data mod link Index
Windows function à Windows function thì
tôi không nắm chắc đâu có khi tôi không
dám chơi cái này Windows function là
Ờ nó thiên về bên Ms SQL Microsoft SQL
tôi lại không dùng Cái đấy tôi chuyên
bên myq
hơn Nó là kiểu dạng đây cho tra lại này
Windows function cho mấy ông tôi còn
chưa dạy mấy ông về Windows
function cái bản chất Windows function
này Thực ra là nó không hẳn cái khó chên
tôi chưa dùng bao
giờ nó là cách viết
cái liên quan đến A Microsoft SQL như
thế này chắc tôi phải nắm chắc Microsoft
SQL đã không thì thi cũng không làm được
vì tôi có nhiều ph ch Tôi không biết này
Window function nha nó Nó là một tập hợp
cái thứ thứ giống như nó cũng giống aggr
mà hồi trước tôi từng dạy giống như là
max hay là Min hay cái gì gì đó hay sao
như này nhưng mà nó khác một tí nữa nó
khác tở điểm là câu truy vấn nó sẽ
với partition không biết partition là
cái gì bởi vì nói chung là chưa chư động
cái là kiến thức này L không áp dụng ở
bên
Cái này là riêng của Microsoft SQL và nó
không áp dụng ở bên mysql nên thực ra là
tôi không rõ
lắm
Index
pivot pivot có phải pivot t bồ không nhá
đỡi Tí binh Tĩnh m không cứ đòi chơi hot
nhưng mà có hiểu đâu mà chơi
này tôi làm cái này trước sub thì tôi
làm được Union tôi biết
này
m có Passion kia đâ xem nhá Thế là tôi
còn thiếu luôn kiến thức về cái
[âm nhạc]
Ồ tôi tôi chưa dùng cái này bao giờ
này trước được rồi Nếu thế thì tôi tôi
sẽ nợ bạn các bạn về cái này tôi chưa
Tôi chưa được động vào nên tôi cũng
không không dám tôi xin phép Hôm nay có
thể làm trước được cả hai cái này cũng
được basic dễ D ba cái
kiểu phân Tám đây nó có Windows function
này tôi chưa dùng cái này đầu tiên có
bảng hacker
subquery nói chung là lấy cái này từ
phân tán từ cái này
[âm nhạc]
à ra ok
nó giống kê
sub B thấy rồi À không vậy
[âm nhạc]
chưa không Tôi sẽ chỉ chơi basic về
interm rồi xem à
inter mediate à phát âm từ này
nha trung gian mới biết rồi này
hẳn Joy phức tạp luôn nó chung hôm nay
tôi sẽ chơi hai cái này được chưa
ngắm tôi trai hot Tôi vừa rồi tôi vừa
nói là tôi cảm thấy đang hạnh phúc Ờ
tiện ích á Google dịch Google Translate
cái tôi vừa nói đó là mình làm thầy rồi
mình được cái vui ở để mà mình đi bắt
nạt người khác đi bắt người khác ép
người khác thi ch mình không phải thi
nữa mình đỡ phải mình đỡ phải kiểu thi
cử đỡ phải lo việc thi cử sau cuối cùng
bây giờ mình vẫn Phả thi hả Lộ sẽ điệ
thoại à lộ từ mấy buổi hôm trước rồi mấy
ông còn biết được cái địa chỉ nhà tôi
rồi chưa sợ tôi sợ mấy ông đế đánh
thô đến mắng kiểu sao thi tệ thế cũng
được ok nhá basic trước này xong rồi cái
trung gian nhá Còn tôi tôi sẽ cân nhắc
về cái vụ nâng cao này bởi vì nâng cao
này thì ra nó lại liên quan đến bên mấy
cái hàm mà tôi không biết lắm Nếu mà giả
sử chuyên sâu lại chuyên sâu ở bên bên
msql thì chắc là tôi
Ờ tôi tự tin hơn còn ở bên ma à fql
server th hỏi tôi bây giờ chắc là tôi đã
dạy mấy kiến thức mấy ông biết ấy thì nó
chck cer này nó là
à chck cer à function hoặc là gì nhở sao
tự nhiên quên mất tên rồi proced thì
biết đấy chứ còn bây giờ hỏi tôi Windows
function hay mấy cái có thể là nó không
hẳn nâng cao phức tạp giống như là bằng
thằng tricker tôi Tôi nghĩ là như thế
nhưng mà mình lại chưa dùng bao giờ nên
không tự tin đâu Tôi không tự tin quả
đấy
đâu à Ctrl w thì sẽ đóng Tab hoặc là
đóng Nói chung là đóng cái cửa sổ khá
nhanh bắt đầu
nhá bắt đầu đi dài dòng trình bảy hai
câu
hỏi hai câu hỏi TH Chắc dễ nhỉ À Làm thử
bài trước không không gày sớm làm thử
trước
Ờ em làm được chẳng lẽ thầy không Không
Ông đừng có chém tôi Tôi không thể bị
sấu mặt trước đông người được
Company ID name
employee số lượng nhân viên
cần nh toàn bộ ID danh sách ID của
Company có hơn 10.000 employee À sắp xếp
theo thứ tự tăng dânn dễ
Company à bắt buộc viết hoa chẳng biết
phải viết hoa hay không
được à Cái này MQ này
ồ hấp dẫn hấp dẫn
lừa
employe cứ viết hoa viết hoa hết đi nh
tự nhiên bị đánh sai chỉ vì viết thưng
lại cười rồi
Ờ chấm Phi còn gì không nhỉ
ờ bình tĩnh
hơn
10.000 Chắc
thế kế danh sách số nó h thị ra kiểu như
này chắc là
nên đừng có n kểu submit
vội sai
xem
này À sắp xếp và theo ID tăng dần à thế
cái này quan trọng
dễ cái câu Tôi vừa làm à quên phải chấm
phẩy nữa đậu xanh
kểu à correct answer à Ok
con gì
rồi X rồi mà Ôi bịp không quay lại này
nữa
rồi bắt đầu thôi đúng
không đề bắt đầu nhiều chữ hơn rồi
đấy Ok chắc chắn là select rồi đúng
không đâu bình tĩnh nhá Để tôi chắt lọc
thông tin nó nhá promote bla BL bla vân
vân vân
file file employ ID này đúng không chc
chắn là select ID rồi đúng không Không
quan tâm nó là
employ
E ID đấy tự nhiên nó hứng viết hoa bắt
trước theo nó
nhá along with the name đúng không Ok
name này Đấy name này thêm cái này cho
chắc chắn nó không bị không bị kiểu
thành từ khóa
the HR
department HR department tức là division
sẽ là HR đúng
bằng
HR Thực ra bằng ở trong myq nhớ lm lầm
viết thường cũng được
Ờ đấy from
bonus in last
quarter h
sang bảng này một là nó nối sang hai tôi
chơi suby cho tôi sẽ có hai cách một là
mình có thể join sang cho cho nó
nhanh mình sẽ Joi sang thằng à Thằng này
chi thằng này sau đó thì mình sẽ
We cái bonus Nó lớn hơn
5000 Nhưng mà nếu thế thì có thể ID nó
có thể lặp lại đúng không nhở ID có thể
lặp lại mà đúng không đâu ID Thằng này
chắc chẳng lặp lại đâu như tôi muốn làm
đ c sub đi and
last
quarter
khen nó format hay nó nó lại xấu rồi đấy
We này
bonus
à Lớn
hơn
5000 lớn bằng đi
5000 Chắc là
được nghĩa câu này sẽ lấy ID và tên
trong bảng này với điều kiện là cái cột
này phải HR và danh sách ID nằm trong
danh sách ID mà được
thưởng
5000 dễ mà chạy thử
có biết gì V kênh này đâu chẳng biết
kênh này có nhiều kênh Tôi không biết
mang tiếng là kênh dành cho dân công
nghệ
Ồ trên này nó cũng có cái vụ auto
mà 5000 mà bị và a nhm xin lỗi
đề tôi gõ sai rồi
mà bên bên này thì
cùng không th tôi ngồi mò
ờ Làm gì mà ấy nhỉ đậu xành Chắc mấy ông
cũng tham gia chơi cùng Đúng không mấy
ông kiểu vào đ doot server của nó đúng
không Ok
submit rồi Câu thứ hai
ờ query file stock code stock code đây
đúng
table table có lợi nhuận Nếu mà tôi hiểu
như
giá hôm sau tăng thì nó sẽ có nghĩa làm
chỉ là mình sẽ join mình sẽ join là dễ
nhất mình join Jo cho dễ đi mình sẽ Jo
kiểu mình sẽ lấy stock code mình sẽ lấy
mình Jo hai thằng này với nhau rồi mình
lấy stock code thằng nào cũng được nhưng
mà bản chất là mình sẽ phải que theo với
điều kiện này giá thằng này nhỏ hơn giá
thằng này thế là được mình sẽ from chú
đy nhưng mà chẳng thào về sau m không
được phép để tên bảng kiể
như
Thế tao có cái auto complete này có tác
dụng gì vậy
alo
chịu ngại Mỗi hệ vụ tên bảng nó không
cho đặt tên Đây là add t đi về p đi thì
mình sẽ
on t
chấm stock code này bằng p chấm Đấy
không hề gợi ý nhá của chả ta gì cả ờ Và
thậm chí là ông một ông que được hay là
tôi sẽ on à en luôn tại đây Tôi thích
cái en luôn tại đây Tại sao bởi vì ở đây
sẽ có hai tình huống ở đây xảy ra cho
mấy ông nhá một là ông que như này p chm
prim lớn hơn t. prim như này đúng không
Nhưng mà cái này nó sẽ là khi ông join
mất rồi thì ông mới bắt đầu We nghĩa là
ông giả sử bên bảng này có 10.000 sản
phẩm bên này 10.000 sản phẩm Xong rồi
ông join xừ với nhau rồi ông mấy que để
lọc thì thay vì như thế thì ông sẽ có
thể ngay cái đoạn join này này thì ông
sẽ en luôn ở đây cho tôi đấy trong
trường hợp tôi thường hay làm như này
trong trường hợp vừa để lọc bớt dữ liệu
vừa để vừa để à Vừa để kiểu dạng là Ờ
nói chung là lọc bớt dữ liệu cho cái cái
này nó nhẹ khi mà chi vào thứ hai là tôi
chỉ làm như này khi mà khi mà kiểu Dạ nó
liên quan đến các cột ở trong cái bảng
này thì tôi sẽ làm kiểu như này nhưng mà
tôi không hiểu thằng này có hiểu ý tôi
Không cái này đơn giản mà thằng này lớn
hơn giá thằng này profitable
mà short à SH
à asent order nghĩa nó Sẽ só như
nào Thằng chữ G G trước chữ t nhở đúng
không bảng chữ cái mà đúng không
quan trọng gì nữa Cột nào cũng như
đúng
không xong rồi nhỉ
lúc phải xem kết quả bài này Ok Ok nếu
thế Mình phải chơi hai bài cùng lúc để
nhận kết quả cả hai
bài Thế à Thế rồi à Cũng dễ nhỉ Ừ thì
đúng là bài basic có hai câu mà vừa nãy
vừa đọc có hai câu
Ờ Thử xem cái này có bao nhiêu câu
nhá basic mà Mấy ông mong đợi kiểu
gì Bài này bài bao nhiêu phút 35 phút
Ok 35 phút cũng hai câu Ok
Ok thử tôi cứ thử trước đã không nên cải
sớm
a Thư thử cái này lại
vẻ được đấy
Ờ tất cả không không được bán hợp lý hợp
lý
này ID này à đâu U
này product name
này
form nhìn nó gợi ý mỗi cái này thôi á
Gọi Ý Keyword
hai ok không gợi ý tên bản nhưng gợi ý
select from th thứ gợi ý chữ không không
gợi ý
gợi ý không không gợi ý đúng mỗi chỗ
form à gợi ý chữ select không à Có gợi ý
chữ select Ok thông minh
Tôi chắc chắn là tôi không không tự hào
vào cái nụ cười của mình rồi cửu là cười
đẹp hay cười thân thiện hay cái gì gì đó
cả nhưng mà tôi tự tin là tôi hay cười
đấy
danh dung mục đã bán thì đơn giản thì
mình sẽ lấy product ID này from
invoice
item Ừ đúng rồi thông minh ở hai chữ đấy
thôi auto complete ready hiểu không
Ờ thế là được thôi mình sẽ không nằm
trong cá sách đấy dễ nhỉ thêm cái order
by nữa order by S C thại sao nó cứ thêm
đoạn này kiểu nhở Tại sao phải đi xuống
nhỉ thử
còn hơn Kiểu tao không có cái gì cả Xong
rồi đột nhiên kiểu nó gợi ý ra nó còn
hơn r kiểu đã sẵn sàng hiểu không Đã sẵn
sàng nhưng mà Uy có thể tắt nó đi này ồ
tí rồi tắt nó
thầy nghe sa sai
ờ op of customer
select user
thì first name and last name cái gì đấy
À đợi đợi tí đ tí nhá
không contact gộp hai thằng này với nhau
thằng này nối qua hai bảng này với mỗi
một cặp thì hiển thị user Company à user
ID l name user ở đây
là à user account này ok
là kế toán kiểu thế đây khách hàng một
khách một kế toán nhiều khách hàng nên
bây giờ sẽ hiển thị thông tin của kế
toán s kèm theo số lượng của ờ khách
hàng đúng không
nà
gì tôi còn đang không hiểu cái đề tôi
không học đại học không ạ
thông cont
là kiểu số lần liên hệ n chẳng biết con
contact time này nghĩa là
gì bỏ qua mình không cần biết điều đấy
Ờ ba bảng nhiều gì rồi làm chục bảng C
được rồi Nhưng mà quan trọng tôi không
về hiểu cái đề lắm đâ Xem mại nhá Pe là
cặp đúng không Mình sẽ cần hiển thị ra
cái cặp đúng không Mình sẽ hiển thị cặp
gì user ID này mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ có
là user ID này user first name này
trước
đi user last name này đấy đúng không ạ
customer ID này
customer customer name này
Đấy number of the contact Tức là chỉ là
mình
có đề cập là cái này có Union và subc
tôi đang nghĩ cái này nó sẽ liên quan
đến
Union nó sẽ là sao nó không phải mỗi
join nữa ền là cũng gộp hai bảng
thằng này chẳng có join gì cả Mình sẽ
select thằng này trước sau đó thì Union
với cái thang này sau đó thì mình mới
select subquery để lấy thông tin từ bảng
này Ừ chắc là được đấy
thử nhá Ờ tôi sẽ ra ID này last name này
first name
này dễ mà Nhưng mà quan trọng mình hiểu
đề
rồi này đây như này đúng
bạn chất cái này khi mà chạy này nó là
một bàng đúng không Mình sẽ Union này Ồ
nó gợi ý này xị không
xị
Ờ à Không customer thì nó chỉ có
customer name thôi
customer
name
này
Ừ mình sẽ có ID này Tôi đặt tên cái này
là C
đi cái này u đi đấy Union hai thằng
nhưng mà thức á Union kiểu này không
được nhở vì rõ ràng là lệch số
tí số cột nó bị
kiểu này không ng làn được nhầm đấy nhầm
đấy Không không không như thế Ở đây mình
cần làm như th nào nhỉ
Ừ đị ra thông tin của khách hàng thông
tin này Thế rốt cuộc là đĩa
số cái con số này
À ha này nó nối với nhau kiểu gì
ờ i
nhau qua thằng này rồi
thế th à uid Này first name
mắc cái tiê đ cái đề bài một tí thôi Tôi
không nghĩ bài bài khó vẫ làm
cơ tiêu đề nào for key nào à for key à Ừ
đúng rồi mình sẽ nối bảng nào trước bảng
nào cũng được đúng không
Ờ chất cái này phải dùng join thôi không
có le Joy phức tạp làm gì cả
user account add à đâu phải cho
thằng này trước contact
add không Chẳng cần add gì cả
on contact ch customer ID bằng cid rồi
join tiếp với
u onu ch ID bằng
contact
chấm user
thì mình hiển thị được thông tin rồi còn
number of z contact thì mình sẽ phải C
nữa nhưng mà tôi đang không biết grou bu
kiểu gì Chắc group
buy user ID
ờ rõ ràng là hai thằng này nó Ừ phải
group by hai thằng này vậy cao này cao
sao thì chẳng hạn add
chẳng
by g ý xịn xịn
chấm chẳng cần
ID phải c. ID bởi vì rõ ràng là nó dựa đ
hai cột này tôi nghĩ thế này chắc là
được à order by nữa
orderby
Xem thế cái Union vết ở đâu
vi group by cho toàn bộ vào đây thế là
group by
bắt buộc phải lấy những người nào đã
liên hệ quá hơn một một lần
Alo thế Cái này Union ở chỗ nào bịp à
bịt
nhỉ Như cho đùa vậy
thế thôi á
bỏ lỡ điều gì à Hả rõ ràng tôi vừa bỏ lỡ
gì đúng không tại sau 40 phút xong hai
câu câu một thì dễ không nói làm gì câu
hai thì cũng bình thường nhưng mà C ên ở
chỗ nào nhỉ Chẳng lẽ làm nốt Câ cuối cho
đủ Một tiếng nhỉ
không biết được cách gì vừa rồi để chạy
Union ấy bởi vì
à số cột nó lệch nó không thể nói chung
là dùng join vừa rồi
Union là gì á Nó đại khái là kiểu bình
thường ông dùng join là ông phải có hai
cột nó có có dữ liệu chung để ông nối
vào với nhau và ông sẽ là là nối theo
hàng ngang đây tôi sẽ chỉ mấy ông à qu
Excel
nhá Tôi chưa dạy mấy ông về Union Bởi vì
thực ra là đi làm ít dùng bởi vì nó rất
là nặng ít dùng lắm mấy ông có thể có
vài cái mớ không thể nghiên cứu thêm
Ờ ví dụ là kiểu vừa rồi vừa rồi Giả sử
là trong tình huống vừa rồi Nói chung là
có khách hàng đúng không customer đúng
không Đây ID này name này đúng không x
rồi thêm C tuổi chẳng hạn Giả sử thế với
user
à user này cũng có ID có name này có x
này giả sử là nó có ba cột như này thằng
lại có ba cột như này bên này có 1000
khách hàng rồi Bên này 1000 người dùng
chẳng hạn thế và ông muốn lấy tất cả
người dùng và tất cả các khách hàng để
in ra và nằm trong bảng này kiểu dạng
như vừa rồi đây nó kiểu bảng user thêm
chữ s chẳng hạn à không phải bảng nhưng
nói chung Ông cần muốn đổ hết toàn bộ ra
ấy thì ông có thể là dùng Câ lệnh là sel
ID name x from customer sau đó thì cái
dưới này cũng giống hệt là user đúng
không như này nếu mà ông select hai câu
độc lập như này thì rõ ràng là là nó ra
dữ liệu cũng rất rất giống nhau ở điểm
có ba cột nhưng mà Thông tin Dữ liệu nó
khác nhau thôi đúng không Thì ông hoàn
toàn thể Union hai cái này với nhau ông
chỉ nó có khái niệm là Union o vào Union
à Tôi nhớ là có những cái Union gì không
nhớ lắm Union à Union là kiểu nối với
nhau
ấy để tôi xem
mà Mấy ông ghi ngắn gọn Union thì sẽ
Union o nghĩa là ghép cả giá trị của cả
bên này cả bên này vào đó còn intersect
là kiểu lấy điểm chung thì tôi nghĩa là
nó giống join Còn cái này loại trừ n nào
giống Jo nhưng mà nhớ cái này nó khác
Joi ấy nó khác chi đấy đại khái g đây nó
phân biệt giữa Nếu mà Joy thì ông sẽ
ghép hai cột này nằm bên cạnh như này
còn Union thì tức là ông sẽ chèn thêm dữ
liệu vào xuống dưới như th này Đấy phân
biệt Union với join như thế không không
không phải dùng join
mà join thì bản chất là dữ liệu nó nằm
song song hai bên còn Union thì nó sẽ là
chèn thêm vào đoạn ở dưới như thế này
này dữ liệu sẽ đẩy xuống dưới và và nó
còn tự động ghi đè lên nếu mà giả sử là
ờ cái intersect hay cái gì gì đó nó sẽ
tự động ghi đè lên cơ Nếu thật sự cùng
chung cái Key hay ch cùng chung cái gì
đó nó sẽ ghi đè
ra bản chất là nó một cái table Ảo thì
đúng đúng nó sẽ là một cái table mới lưu
giá trị của hai thằng cái thằng này full
outer Joy này này bạn bỏ cái on này đi
thì nó sẽ bằng cái Union đấy À không
nhưng với điều kiện Union là phải đủ số
cột giống như tôi vừa bảo ấy số cột phải
khớp nhau nhá số cột mà lệch nhau thì
ông không un được đấy thế
thôi Nhìn cái này trong ngứa mắt nhỉ
thử không data moder link Index kể biết
này
pivot pivot là gì nhỉ piv được rồi Hình
như cũng liên quan đến Window function
mà nhở đúng
Ờ cái group bu vừa nãy là sao á bởi vì
group buy bản chất là nó nhóm lại thực
ra là cái tôi vừa rồi mấy ông thấy vừa
rồi trong group bu của tôi nó là nhó lại
kiểu để lọc lọc lọc Nếu giả sử trùng đây
ví dụ giả sử ở đây có một này Long
này kiểu như
này chẳng biết để để tôi
hình dung hơn
nhá contact vừa rồi đúng không Mình sẽ
có customer ID
này
Ờ ví dụ là số lần liên hệ này là number
đi Đấy mình liên
hệ mình liên hệ kiểu tận ba lần như này
chẳng hạn đúng không giả sử giả sử như
này thôi nhá x ng đi này nếu mà giả sử
mà ông join thằng này với thằng này nếu
mà join thuần thôi đúng không thì đồng
nghĩa việc là khi m Joy ấy nó sẽ lặp lại
dữ liệu kiểu như này một này đây sẽ là
customer ID nhá à 1 này rồi number sẽ
lặp đi lập lại là 1 này 2 này 3 như này
nếu mà ông chỉ dạn join vào thằng này
với thằng này đúng không Thì ông Nếu
không không phải distance trong trường
hợp này mà bản chất là nó đúng là kiểu
nó sẽ loại trùng ông sẽ group buy theo
customer ID Nếu ông group byy customer
ID thì thì đúng là nó loại trùng theo
cái cột này thôi Giả sử cột này trùng
không nó sẽ loại lại Xóa hết toàn bộ đi
nó sẽ sẽ kiểu đúng còn như này nhưng thế
này sai bản chất rõ ràng number bây giờ
nó phải lên số 3 và và nó phải cần có cả
ba giá trị chứ không phải là một giá trị
này đúng không thì đây là một cái đó là
thứ nhất là cái này mặc định sẽ lấy cái
đầu tiên hay cái cuối cùng tôi cũng nhớ
lắm hình như lấy cái đầu tiên thôi phải
và và ông muốn ông khi ông dùng group
buy theo customer ID này ông không nên
lấy cái cột ở trong cái bảng kia như thế
này vì giá trị bây giờ không còn đúng
nữa ông ông phải thế nên là thế nên là
nó sẽ luôn cảnh báo ông là ông không
được phép lấy cái cột này giống như vừa
rồi nó cảnh báo nhá Cái lỗi mà Mấy ông
vừa thấy là trong thằng Microsoft SQL
thì nó sẽ luôn báo lỗi là ông không được
phép select kiểu như này bởi vì sai mặ
bản chất thì rõ ràng là thằng này vừa
rồi nó có tận ba giá trị chứ không phải
là một giá trị như này đúng không ạ
Nhưng mà đối với M SQL thì nó cảnh báo
nhưng nó vẫn cho chạy và nó sẽ hiển thị
ra mỗi kết quả đầu tiên như thế này
thành ra là đấy là sai mặt bản chất thế
nên là khi mà ông group B theo một cột
như này thì ông sẽ phải ông sẽ phải làm
gì ông sẽ chỉ có thể
dùng nên dùng những cái hàm là cái hàm
kiểu XM này hàm cao đếm Ví dụ ở đây cao
number chẳng hạn cao là đếm xem là số
lần liên hại liên hệ bao nhiêu lần hoặc
là max max number nghĩa là tổng à lần số
lần cao nhất liên hệ là bao bao giờ
chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ ra 3 đúng không ạ
Đấy thì
nhưng mà vừa rồi là mình muốn lấy rất
nhiều thông tin khác ở đây muốn lấy thêm
cả name chẳng hạn đúng không ạ thì rõ
ràng là ông sẽ ông ở đây ở đây muốn lấy
thêm name nữa đúng không ạ thì ông ông
lại phải à group by theo cả cái name thì
ông mới lấy được vào nhưng nó có một tí
nhược điểm đó là cái này Thực ra tình
huống này gần như không xảy ra vì ID của
ông không được phép lặp Nhưng nếu Giả sử
về sau ID của ông được lặp Bằng lý do gì
đ đó thì ví dụ Giả sử tên nó Huy ở đây
chẳng hạn như này nếu mà ông group bu
theo cả customer ID và customer name như
thế này thì nó sẽ bị lặp lại dữ liệu như
này thật đây như này và đúng là nó sẽ ra
là ba như th này nhưng mà đương nhiên là
cái vụ ID này là duy nhất Nên là chắc là
ông phải lo ông group bu theo một cái
cột chắc chắn nó là duy nhất sau đó thì
ông lấy theo những cái cột khác cùng
nhưng ông phải thêm cái cột đấy vào
trong group bu Cho dù tôi thấy cái cái
việc thêm cột đấy vào trong group bu nó
không còn đúng bản chất nữa vì rõ ràng
là mình nó hơi sai vì nếu Giả sử name Nó
có
thể nó có thể khác nó không trùng thì
thì đúng là nó sẽ lặp lại thành hai bản
ghi giống như tôi vừa nói như th này nếu
mà ông group B theo mỗi customer ID thì
nó sẽ lặp lại à group by customer ID và
customer name thì ông sẽ đúng là lặp lại
như thế này nhưng do customer ID nó duy
nhất rồi nên là điều này không ba giờ
xảy ra
đấy nhưng mà đấy là trong trường hợp để
cái này duy nhất thôi thường thường về
sau ông ở công ty lớn thì ông lại xóa
hết mấy cái con chết mấy cái Giàng buộc
ví dụ kiểm tra check là priv key tự động
tăng ấy không dùng nữa này
ông ông không dùng khóa ngoại nữa này
ông không dùng che trủng gì nữa ông
không dùng unic nữa thì có thể sẽ về sao
có thể có tình huống gì đó Kiểu cái ID
này trùng ra rồi Gì gì đó Nói chung cũng
nguy hiểm
phết Private piv pivot pivot select này
thành một cái bảng
V thử ví dụ xem nhá
[âm nhạc]
và cái vừa rồi cái vừa rồi cũng là một
cái đúng rồi tăng hiệu suất bởi vì nó
nếu mà giả sử code của ông chắc chắn là
nó luôn kiểm tra trước rồi mà nó luôn
Đúng rồi thì ông để con chest nữa Thì
thằng SQL nó xử lý nó lại phải kiểm tra
phát nữa Mỗi khi mà ups à Insert update
hoặc thậm chí Delete ấy thì nó sẽ rất là
nặng với database nên là thực ra về sau
sẽ loại đi hoặc thậm chí là chuyển sang
no SQL chẳng hạn no SQL thì nó chẳng có
một cái kiểm tra gì cả dữ liệu ông Nhật
và bất cứ cái gì nó cũng hợp lệ thành ra
là ông sẽ phải cân nhắc về về về mấy cái
code của ông vies rất cẩn thận chứ không
phải để cho database Vi đoạn đấy
hôm trước vừa hỏi luôn về cái group
concast này group concast này hình như
mai mai queo có tôi không nhớ là
Microsoft SQL có không nhưng đại khái
giống như vừa rồi mấy ông thấy là ở đây
giả sử là tôi vẫn muốn lấy ra cái số
number như
này theo tương ứng với từng người dùng
Nhưng tôi sẽ muốn liệt kê toàn bộ cái n
number của người dùng ra theo kiểu là 1
2 3 như th này nẽ có bao nhiêu hiển thị
hết ra Đấy như thế này và vẫn chỉ muốn
là vẫn chỉ muốn là kiểu chỉ có một khách
hàng thôi kiểu dạng à không phải một
khách hàng mà group buy theo customer ID
Thôi thì mình sẽ câu truy vấn sẽ là
select cái gì gì đó ba cột này đúng
không À đây ID này name này và thêm một
cái nữa group concast này number như này
đó Thế là xong đấy được không ạ sau đó
mình sẽ
from Hai thằng này join với nhau đúng
không ạ xong rồi mình sẽ group buy theo
ID và name Đấy thế là xong thì cái grp
concast này nó sẽ nhóm cái cái cột cái
cột này cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy nhưng nó
nó còn thêm được vài cái hay nữa đó giả
sử ông muốn Giả sử ông chỉ muốn lấy top
2 thôi chẳng hạn và và sắp xếp theo thứ
tự thứ tự kiểu giảm dần chẳng hạn thế
ông chỉ muốn là ba xong rồi hai như này
chẳng hạn thì thằng group concast này nó
sẽ có thể thêm cho ông là Limit 2 sau đó
thì order by cái gì gì đó nữa Rất là hay
như th
này đó Thế là xong thì nó sẽ cái group
concast này nó cũng giống như hàm min
max một cái gì đó thôi Nghĩa là nó có
tác dụng khi mà ông dùng group buy và
cái này hợp là nó sẽ nối cái dự nối cái
giá trị của cái cột mà ông muốn cách
nhau vở dấu phẩy tô nhớ không lầm như có
thể nối bằng cách nhau bằ cái dấu khác
cũng được nhưng đại khái như thế và hoàn
toàn có thể sắp xếp được ngay trong
chính cột này đấy Sắp xếp ở đây ở trong
chính cột này nó độc lập sắp xếp ở ngoài
nhá ông giả sử Ông sắp xếp ở ngoài Cái
gì gì đó không quan tâm bên trong này nó
vẫn có cái kiểu sắp xếp riêng và nó có
Limit riêng ở bên ngoài ông Limit là l
một cái khác order by một cái khác m
không hình dung không đấy group concast
nó tác dụng như thế
tổng hợp lại được thêm một vài câu hỏi
nữa Ờ nhưng mà vẫn chắc vẫn chưa đủ vẫn
vẫn còn nhiều câu hỏi tôi chưa trả lời ắ
Nói chung là cái này tôi xin phép trả
lời buổi sau này còn cái gì không nhỉ
ờ angula không biết này x sá chịu này CS
quá kém này chịu chịu ra
scp ra skip basic đ tôi chơi ra skip Cái
này có khi tôi không biết đâu
quen Có khi cái này không biết N Kệ bây
giờ có pp tôi chơi
Ờ pp thôi không ạ Tôi có phải chuyên về
bên ng ngữ khác rồi tôi tôi tư tin về
SQL với P Java đi anh à tôi cái hôm thi
Java tôi ngồi làm bằng pp ông biết không
Ờ thậ toán á Thật toán càng không ở trên
trường tôi học thật toán rồi tôi biết
cái bài này
tôi tôi sẽ cứ phải tự tin phải chuẩn bị
trước đã đúng không tự tin chuẩn bị
trước đã
ơ nhở tí xem mình được giải gì chứ
không được rồi đúng không
Ồ hấp dẫn hấp dẫn rồi Kiểu đăng lên
l hay thế nhỉ
Ồ nhưng mà cái này trông không oai không
ạ Tôi sẽ kiếm được rồi Hẹn nợ C bạn à
Buổi buổi khác tôi sẽ làm ngon r tôi sẽ
đăng lên l kân của tôi cho nó
tôi toàn được hỏi mấy cái câu kiểu giọng
như là tìm à làm à kiểm tra xem Đấy là
số a số nguyên
lại chơi thế chắc tạch thì cũng lắm là
được à Ờ được thi lại sau giống kiểu len
ấy sau 6 tháng sau được thi lại
qua đầu tiên thì tâm tâm sự một tí nha
tâm sự hay trả lời câu hỏi trước nhỉ À m
tôi xin phép
nghỉ thứ năm và thứ bảy thứ năm này thì
ờ năm này thì C Sếp của tôi ở bên ở bên
Úc với bên Mỹ thì phải về kiểu liên hoan
Nói chung là công ty tôi là công ty về
cơ bản là công ty Toàn xếp người Việt
nhưng mà ở bên nước ngoài trực bên nước
ngoài à thành lập bên nước ngoài vân vân
mãi bây giờ vãn dịch rồi thì mới cơ hội
được gặp sếp đấy thì sếp về nên là cũng
liên hoan Nên là chắc là tối thứ năm thì
không a không online dạy mới ông được v
lúc đấy Có thể tôi đang đứng hát karaoke
Ờ tiếp theo là thứ Bảy thì thứ bảy này
là nói chung là ngay từ hôm 29 là tôi đã
bắt đầu đi nghỉ mát rồi thứ ra tôi ít
khi đi nghỉ mát nếu có một sự thật thì
tôi từng nói mấy ông đó là Tết tôi vẫn
còn ngồi code hai mùng mng ba Tết tôi
vẫn đang ngồi cốt nên là thực ra tôi ít
khii chơi lắm nhưng mà do sinh nhật mẹ
và sinh nhật mẹ thì thường mẹ tôi muốn
tôi đi nghỉ mát một tí nên thành ra tôi
sẽ nói chung là tôi sẽ cố về vào trước
thử ba tuần sau để mà để mà kiểu dậy đấy
bởi vì rõ ràng là nghỉ tôi công ty tôi
thì mặc định đã nghỉ thứ bảy chủ nhật
rồi đấy Xong
rồi tối ngày tối thứ Sáu đi này xong rồi
được nghỉ thứ hai thứ ba nghỉ bù mà đấy
nhưng mà thứ ba k gì tôi sẽ về trước để
tôi còn dạy cho mấy ông nói chung là
à tôi xin phép nghỉ vào thứ năm Thứ bảy
nha nói cho ông nào mà không biết được
điều đấy thì đừng trách tôi nhá vì tôi
nói trong livestream rồi hay phải đăng
bài thông báo nhá chá Không sao đâu đôi
khi là mấy ông kiểu đến trường rồi nhận
ra là được nghỉ Cũng vui mà mấy ông còn
chẳng phải đến trườngng tôi nghĩ là cùng
lắm là mấy ông ngồi đợi một tí kiểu Ơ
sao ông anh hôm nay không livestream nhỉ
Thế thôi
đấy tôi cứ mỗi lần đến trường mà được
nghỉ tôi vui lắm rẽ luôn ra Quá nét Tôi
không bao giờ kiểu khó chịu như vài
người kìa ô mất giấc ngủ Các th thứ
không sướng đến trường thấy thông báo
được nghỉ sướng lắm Ờ
mang tiếng là tôi đi nghỉ mát thế Như
tôi chắc là tôi vẫn phải mang con laptop
này đi may là tôi mới mua con laptop khá
là gọn nhẹ để vác đi bởi vì nếu có vấn
đề gì đó là cũng phải mở máy đi làm việc
nhưng mà đấy là mang laptop đi mà để mà
gọi là code tạm thôi chứ để mà
livestream thì hơi khó nói chung là
không có mic này nhiều cái nữa Nói chung
là bây giờ đang chơi hai màn lúc đấy một
màn không cân được đấy
vào trong Nam rồi t lâu lắm không g Anh
đấy Anh ấy đi theo tiếng gọi con team
Thực ra tôi đang có hướng đến một tí đó
là là làm streamer ấy hôm trước có bạn
bảo là anh thử livestream để mà
Ờ hôm trước là đi Tôi đi bên FBT
Software để mà kiểu tham quan bên đấy
các thứ thứ ấy Và thậm chí là tôi tôi
bảo tôi định về bên đấy Dậy ấ thậm chí
là thậm chí là tôi còn đang định về sớm
hơn không phải đợi 4 năm nữa mà tôi đang
định sẽ sẽ qua dậy ở bên r Tân ở Cầu
Giấy trước vàoi lớp buổi tối thì tôi nói
chung là tôi định livestream không phải
livestream nhưng cũng định quay lại và
video gì gì đó để mà kiểu cho các bạn
hình dung qua bởi vì nói chung là phòng
up các thứ trông đẹp lắm trông hiện đại
khác với cái hồi mà tôi dạy ở ở trường
cũ vì trường cũ về cơ bản là trường này
bé không hiện đại bằng nhưng mà nhưng mà
thực sự ấy thì tôi vẫn chưa quen được
cái tôi chưa quen được cái cách quay các
thứ thứ camera của con máy tôi thực ra
là tôi mua con này con Xiaomi 11 10 10
thì camera nó cũng tương đối Nó có thể
quay được 2k hay 4k gì gì đấy nhưng mà
tôi thực ra
tôi chưa quen việc đi chục ảnh rồi quay
lắm sợ mấy ông sẽ chê kết hợp việc à tôi
vẫn chưa có cái người để chỉnh sửa lại
video các thứ thứ thế nên là kiểu không
biết quay kiểu gì Nói chung là chắc là
về sau chắc là tôi sẽ phải hẹn mấy ông
về sau là khi mà tôi không còn dậy này
nữa mà tôi tập trung đi dậy ở ngoài
nhưng mà tôi sẽ thỉnh thoảng có thể quay
cái gì gì đó hoặc là like code hay nói
chung là quay cái gì đó chia sẻ một cái
góc nhìn của một dân công nghệ hay là
cái gì gì đó đúng không ạ thì sẽ được
ừ có khi về sau kiếm cái GoPro gì gì đó
để mà quay không rung chẳng hạn đúng
này của tôi có camera rồi nhưng mà
camera nó thực ra nó cũng chỉ đủ để nhìn
thôi chứ N không xịn đâu và tôi cũng
không muốn là mấy ông nhìn mặt tôi lắm
khi về sau tôi livestream thì chắc là
tôi ít khi à khi mà tôi kiểu quay cái
vừa rồi Tôi nói có khi t ít kiểu quay
mặt tôi
á không tự tin mình đẹp trai lắm
thực ra là con trai chơi đo nó đỡ phải à
gọi là nó
không không đẹp màu mè như mấy Laptop
dòng khác như tôi nghĩ laptop đeo nó
chưa hình dung ý ông lắm
XPS mình sin năm n 97 thưng an
con ông em 96 vãy qua
thuật toán đâu Ông bảo
tôi luyện hả ông muốn ngồi ngồi ngằm Tôi
luyện thật Toán
thôi cứ tâm sự nhá tâm sự đi tâm sự
trước rồi Trả lời câu hỏi
này m ông thể đọc lại Tôi tóm tắt cái
bài này nhá Tôi tóm tắt thôi đó là Ờ ông
này
à 41 tuổi đấy Xong rồi đã đã gần như là
tạo ra cácha với duo Lingo đấy ông kiếm
tiền như thế nào thì ông ông đấy đầu
tiên thì ông ấy kiểu thầy đại khái là
ông ấy toàn nhờ chính cái người dùng của
mình m mic hơi bị giật á Alo hơi bị giật
à Tôi đang nghĩ là hình như là cái đường
chuyền mạng có vấn đề chứ chứ không phải
là do mic giật đâu
Ờ nói chung là ông này kiếm tiền bằng
capcha và duo Lingo Kiểu gì nó là ờ đầu
tiên là cái cái bài toán của cái thằng
capcha này này hồi đấy Đó là để mà cá
tra nó sinh ra để mà à để mà mục đích ở
kiểu Ờ kiểu dạng là tránh spam đúng
không tránh kiểu robot các thứ các thứ
đúng không ạ thì thì mình sẽ thường hay
kiểu à Ngoài việc là nó sẽ kiểu hiển thị
ra mấy cái mấy cái hình ảnh mấy cái chữ
viết bằng tay hay cái gì gì đó hay biển
hiệu gì gì đó hoặc là chụp từ mấy cái
bài báo gì gì đó để yêu cầu người dùng
nhập vào các chữ chữ để mà kiểu nói
chung là kiểu để mà xác nhận người đấy
là người đúng ấy đấy là con người ấy
đúng không ạ thì ngoài việc cái hiển thị
ra đầy thật đấy thì nó lại là nó sẽ dùng
Chính cái cái mà Mấy ông nhập để mà nó
bán cho những cái người khác nó sẽ bán
cho rất nhiều công ty Ví dụ nhiều công
ty giờ có những cái tài liệu hoặc quyển
sách mà họ cần phải nó phải xố hóa xố
hóa tất cả sao nghĩa là họ có những
quyển sách kiểu
dạng kiểu rất khó rất khó là mất công
phải ngồi nhập thủ công lại cái đống đấy
vào máy tính để mà đăng lên mạng thì bây
giờ sẽ có người nhập hộ đúng không ạ
thì đương nhiên là phải có kiểu 10 10
người cùng nhập một chữ thì biết được nó
chính xác đúng không ạ Đấy các thứ thứ
Nên là thành ra là người dùng mình ngoài
việc nhập cá tra cho vui thì à Đúng là
cho vui thì mình là người mà chứ không
phải máy đúng không ạ thì mình đã đã
kiểu gần như là xấu hóa 2,3 triệu quyển
sách thành cái gì gì đó như này đấy mỗi
năm đấy thành ra là ông ấy kiếm tiền
được từ đấy đấy tiếp theo nữa đó là cái
duo Lingo đấy nó lúc đầu nó miễn phí Tôi
không biết bâo giờ nó miễn phí hay mất
phí thì thì nó kiếm tiền bằng cách nào
nó cũng bắt người dùng mình dịch đấy và
mình sẽ Tuy là có thể là mình mấy ông sẽ
bảo là mình là người có phải chuyên
nghiệp đâu mà dịch Chắc chắn là dịch sẽ
rất là dở đúng không ạ nhưng mà đương
nhiên nó sẽ kiểu đây nó bảo này 10 câu
dịch nghiệp dư có thể bằng một câu dịch
chuyên nghiệp đấy Kiểu thế và nó sẽ dịch
hộ cho những cái tài những cái tờ báo
kiểu New York Times này cái gì gì đó rất
nhiều người kiểu rất nhiều nguồn cần
phải dịch sang nhiều ngôn ngữ đúng không
ạ thì chính cái cái người học Mình là
người dịch hộ để mà kiểu nó sẽ đem bán
đi những cái bản thuật dịch đấy đấy thế
nên là nó kiếm lời từ những cái đấy Đấy
thấy không nên là thành ra ông ấy biết
cách để mà biến người dùng một cái thứ
mà tưởng như là miễn phí thường mình
thường hay làm làm mình cũng chẳng chẳng
nhìn được đằng sau của nó đó là mình đã
bị lợi dụng kểu như lợi dụng thì nói từ
đấy hơi quá đáng nhưng mà Đúng là mình
không biết mình không biết được là mình
đã bị kiểu Ờ không phải bị nhưng mà nói
chung là họ có thể kiếm lợi nhuận từ
mình đấy Kiểu thế này công ty đã biết
được chắc chắn là từ đầu tiên hiển thị
là gì Họ sẽ chỉ cần à cái từ đầu tiên
cốt là để kiểm tra xem bạn phải người
hay không rồi cái từ thứ hai mới là từ
mà họ chưa hề biết được từ đấy chưa Số
Hóa Nên là nếu mà từ thứ hai mà cả 10 10
người cùng nhập đúng cái từ ừ từ đấy thì
chứng tỏ là từ đấy Từ Chính xác
theo nữa này cái đấy bài đ tôi chia sẻ
Nhữ hai năm
trước cái này tôi A cái này hay phết này
mấy ông tra mấy cái hàm gì gì đó xong
rồi tên ngôn ngữ xong nó sẽ liệt kê tất
cả các trang mà thường hay kiểu Có code
ví dụ về cái hàm đấy Cái trang tên là
j.com này đấy m không thể nhớ nhớ cái
này
trước là đúng là tôi nhập cá tra để kiếm
tiền hồi tôi từng bị lừa tôi phải đóng
để tôi phải đóng tiền để có cái phần mềm
gì gì đó rồi tôi còn chưa kiếm được đủ
gỡ vốn thì rồi Đã bỏ rồi
trong ngành này thức ra thì
toán thì sẽ khó làm được ngành này không
Em không thông minh sáng dạ lắm em không
làm được ngành này em rốt tiếng Anh Em
Không Làm Được ngành này Vân Vân Vân Vân
rất nhiều lý do về
cái kiểu không theo cái ngành này thì
với tôi quan điểm thì
ờ để tiến xa được trong cái ngành lập
trình này ngành lập trình lập trình nhá
Ờ thì thì đúng là sẽ cần một chút tư duy
ông không thể tư duy kiểu khác người để
làm ngày ngày được ông Tư duy không
giống ai Giống làm sàn sản phẩm chẳng ai
dùng được thì đấy là một người lập trị
viên tồi nên là ông Tư duy phải nói
chung là có không hẳn là rất thông minh
phải có một cái sự kiểu giống người đã
Ờ tiếp theo đó là mấy ông cũng phải chịu
khó một tí tôi đã từng nói đó là m thông
minh quá có khi không theo ngành này
theo bên kinh doanh nó kiếm được tiền dễ
hơn thế ạ Chứ thông minh quá theo ngành
lập trình xong rồi Kiểu bị bị bị khách
hàng chửi hai bữa rồi Chắc là tự ái bỏ
bỏ việc mất đấy Nên là và lỡn cả là
ngành này nó còn là không phải ngoài
việc thông minh tiếp thu nhanh mà nó còn
thay đổi công nghệ cũng rất là chóng mặt
thành ra là cũng khá khó chịu việc đấy
nên thành ra là không
a không không không cần phải thông minh
quá trong ngành này đấy nhưng mà ông
chịu Được cái khô khan thì rất là tốt
cái khô khan là kiểu dạng là kiểu à sinh
sinh viên của tôi có mấy ông kiểu học
BCH khoa chẳng hạn
Ờ mấy ông ấy kiểu đọc được đống tài liệu
khố khann xong rồi hiểu kiểu ngồi đọc
mấy cái thuật toán các thứ thứ tôi không
chịu được mấy cái đấy tôi cảm thấy đọc
cái đấy nó hơi bị đau đầu tí mấy ông ấy
chịu được cái đấy Tôi nghĩ là mấy ông ấy
khá phù hợp trong ngành lập trình Nhưng
mà đấy là chuyên sâu nhưng mà bây giờ
cái ngành công nghệ ông tin này nó không
chỉ dừng mỗi ở Lập trình có một sự thật
là như thế
tôi hình như từng nói qua về cái vụ là
kiểu cái ngành công n nghệ thông tin này
bây giờ rộng lắm Nó có rất nhiều nghề và
rất nhiều cái tên gọi cái gọi là cái cái
gì ạ hiệu danh hiệu cái gọi tên gọi gì
tiêu đề à job
title tiêu đề t chẳng biết
Ờ tiếng Việt nó là gì nhỉ job ti thle
kiểu dạng là kiểu nói chung là đại khái
là nó có nhiều nghề lắm kiểu K thế trong
cái ngành ngành ngành công nghệ công ty
này ông có thể là ông không giỏi về code
Nhưng mà ông lại giỏi về cách kiểu dạng
là tư duy một bài toán giải quyết được
bài toán không Cái toán ở đây nó không
phải là toán học mà bài toán ở đây giả
sử như là sự bâ Bây giờ Bây giờ để giải
quyết một cái ví dụ
là hồi trước để tôi thử ví dụ gì cho mấy
ông dễ hiểu bây giờ nhá đại khái giống
như là người dùng đăng nhập đi người
dùng đăng nhập làm nào để biết người
dùng đang nhập thành công hay thất bại
đúng không ạ người dùng phải nhập đúng
được dữ liệu ở trong cơ sở liệu thì
thành công đúng không ạ Còn không thì in
ra thất bại Cái đấy là một cái rất là
đơn giản nó cũng được tính ở một bài
toán Ờ nó cũng tính một bài toán và và
cái bài toán đấy nó thể khó hơn như thế
nào với cái việc là một cái phần mềm mà
một nghìn người dùng để đăng nhập so 1
triệu người dùng để đăng nhập so đến 1
tỷ người dùng đă nhập tr thằng Facebook
chẳng hạn thì làm cách nào để mà người
dùng đăng nhập vẫn chỉ mất hai đến 3
giây có thể đăng nhập thành công mẹ ông
có thể Ừ nó giống kiểu business anal
tích tất cả kiểu phân tích về thị Phân
tích các thứ các thứ đấy tôi đã nói về
một khía cạnh đấy về sau tôi cũng thích
làm ba đấy Kiểu phân tích các thứ như
thế đấy thì đấy cũng là đấy không Vừa
rồi tôi không phải đề cập cập đến code
gì cả nó đang nói cách xử lý thì mấy ông
sẽ xử lý như nào đấy tương tự thế Nếu
giả sử ông biết về cái ngành này Nhưng
mà ông lại giỏi giao tiếp hơn ông lại
không a ông lại lười cốt gì đó thì ông
nhảy sang mảng nào hoặ ông là con người
cẩn thận tỉ mỉ Nhưng mà ông lại không
giọi code lắm thì ông nhả sang biết tơ
chẳng hạn Vân Vân Vân Nghĩa là ngành này
Thực ra về cơ bản nó có nhiều lắm nó
sinh ra nhiều thứ lắm nó không phải mỗi
lập trình ông học lập trình thức thực ra
là ông mà theo cái khóa nâng cao của tôi
ấ đúng không
Thì thì ông còn đang theo được lập trình
Còn tôi thấy là có rất nhiều bạn đang từ
khóa cơ bản không theo khóa nâng cao nữa
thì tôi biết được là mấy bạn đấy có thể
không thấy không phù hợp với bên lập
trình này nữa Nhưng mấy bạn đấy cũng Tôi
không nghĩ là bạn đấy tìm những cái nghề
phù hợp nữa cũng trong công nghệ thông
tin rõ ràng trong ngành công nghệ công
ty này Thực ra có nhiều
cần cù bù thông minh thì nó không hẳn là
đúng lắm trong ngành này nhưng mà để Ông
đúng là ông muốn lương ông 2i 3000 đô và
đổ lên ấy có thể cao hơn nữa gi kiểu làm
Google ấy thì chắc chắn là ông phải
thông minh rồi đấy chắc chắn nhưng mà
trong ngành Công nghệ thông tin nói
chung này Thực ra có nhiều lắm Thậm chí
là ông chỉ cần EQ giỏi chứ không phải IQ
giỏi cũng làm được nhưng mà không phải
là lập trình đối
đấy tiếp theo đó là
Ờ tôi về Nói chung là 4 năm nữa tôi định
là sẽ làm giảng viên và kết hợp về sau
có thể biết đâu được mờ làm diễn giả gì
đó tốt quá thì và tại sao tôi thích thế
bởi vì tôi có vẻ tôi nói tự tin được chư
Đàm Đông tôi không sợ Đàm Đông ch lắm
cũng hơi run đấy nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy
cũng
muốn làm thế bởi vì tôi từng tôi từng
như như các bạn đến bây giờ vẫn thế đó
là kiểu vẫn thích đi tham gia một cái
Hội thảo công nghệ để xem học hỏi nghe
là nghe các th thứ nhưng tôi thấy là rất
ít cái hội thảo có thể đem lại cho tôi
gọi giá trị các thứ thứ nói thẳng ra tôi
lần hai lần cuối rồii đi cái hội thảo
tôi rủ một ống sinh viên đi để đến từng
cái gian hàng gian chợ để tôi đi lấy quà
Nếu mấy ông theo dõi tôi từ năm ngoái
thì sẽ biết được điều đấy à không Mấy
năm trước cơ bởi vì năm ngoái bị dịch
Nhưng mà đại khái thế tôi sẽ đi từng
gian hàng Tôi đi lấy quà và lấy áo n th
thứ tôi tôi đã từng có hôm tôi tôi chụp
lại đă lên Facebook mà tôi cầm hai Tú
hai túi quà mang về rất nhiều các thứ
thứ rồi Kiểu nhìn tôi trồng trẻ trâu lắm
khi mà đi cùng V bọn sinh viên
nữa xô kiểu chẳng nhận ra ai là thầy Ai
là trò cả kểu thế Ờ Tại sao l như thế
mang tiếng đi hội thảo công nghệ mà mình
lại không nghe l nghe người ta bởi vì à
nó sẽ có ít người thực sự nói kiểu hay
và có có ý nghĩa ở đấy dùng từ thế
Ờ chủ yếu cái hội thảo đấy một là thuê
hẳn một cái ông nào đó kiểu nói như một
ông đa cấp nói B ông đã cấp đấy Nói kiểu
văn vở ngay vẻ hai ăm Nhưng mà thực ra
chẳng có gì cả đấy để giới thiệu về một
loạt các sản phẩm mới cái gì gì đó chứ
không phải là kiểu dạy cho mình một kiến
thức gì đó đấy tiếp theo là nếu mà ông
nào muốn chia sẻ kiến thức thật thì toàn
mấy ông kiểu senio hoặc ch Lead cao hơn
nhưng mà Mấy ông này nói chuyện thì hơi
bị nhàm chán một tí mình chẳng hiểu gì
cả một sự thật là nếu mà mấy cái thằng
Mấy thằng fesser junor mình nghe mình đi
nghe mình chẳng hiu kiểu gì cả đã từng
có ông ngồi nói xong ông ấy mở hẳn trang
code lên à Mở hẳn à IDE lên để sâu sụ
code các th thứ vãi cả trưởng x ông ấy
đọc ông ấy nói từng dòng cô này nghĩa là
gì Cái đấy không phải thuyết trình Cái
đấy không phải một cái ciểu hay để mà
kểu khoe ở ở buổi thuyết trình và nó
không phù hợp làm diễn giả nhưng mà
chảng qua tôi khẳng định là thiếu người
thiếu người để nói hay hay là để mà
nói truyền cảm hứng Vân Vân Vân Được rồi
thành ra phải như thế toàn kiểu mời Ừ
thì bây giờ mấy ông thấy mấy cái gì gọi
banner mấy cái tiêu đề các thứ thứ toàn
giật tít là thạc sĩ này hay là CEO Vân
Vân Vân Vân đúng không ạ Nhưng thực sự
mấy ông lắng nghe mấy người đấy nói
chuyện có khi chán chán hơn so với việc
mấy ông ngồi nghe sắc tanh mang tiếng là
mấy ông doanh nhân nói còn dễ nghe dễ
hiểu hơn vì mấy ông ấy nói chuyện theo
kiểu đa cấp đúng không ạ Đấy nói chung
là cái diện cái Hội thảo công nghệ mà có
người mà vừa nói hay vừa truyển cảm hứng
mà phải biết công nghệ thì nó ít lắm Nó
chỉ có thường là một ông chém gió như
ông đa cấp thế ra chẳng có gì trong đầu
cả hai là một ông đúng nghĩa là ông công
nghệ nhưng mà
Ờ kiểu dạng ông ấy không truyền được cảm
hứng nói hơi bị khô khan người người
dưới chẳng hiểu gì cả đấy m ông Công
nhận là bây giờ mấy ông đi nghe mấy cái
gần đây Nói chung là có kiểu sắc tanh
hay nói chung là mấy cái doanh nhân chia
sẻ Các th thứ còn dễ hiểu hơn cho dù ông
kh phải dân kinh tế đúng không ạ Người
ta còn chia sẻ được nhiều bài học nghe
có vẻ hay nghe Văn V phết đúng không ạ
Còn còn đi hội thảo công nghệ ít khi
nghe được lắm nó cảm thấy thế đương
nhiên là tùy nhiều công ty lớn thì vẫn
là vẫn ví dụ Giả sử điển hình ở Google
Chẳng hạn vẫn có những người giỏi cả hai
màng đấy để
nói nói chung là nó số hơi ít thành ra
về sau tôi muốn là tôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi
là người nói được bên công nghệ Tôi có
thể không cực kỳ giỏi công nghệ bằng mấy
người kia nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi nói
được về công nghệ thì chắc là tôi về sau
tôi đi làm diễn giả được tôi tự tin như
Ơ tôi đang nói là ở Việt Nam mà tôi đ
nói bên ngoài đâu Tôi đã được đi hội
thảo bên ngoài thu lần tôi a tôi mới
được sang nước ngoài à Đúng một lần
nhưng mà để đi du lịch thôi du lịch với
trường Chẳng ham dự cái gì chẳng tham dự
gì đấy cả
ờ cái game bài tuyển dụng này hôm sau
tôi sẽ nói
này cái này liên quan đến code mấy cái
này à đây Ờ hôm trước có bạn hỏi vụ là
bây giờ áp dụng những cái thư viện của
jg có cũ không thức ra là cái này tôi
từng nói rồi chắc là tôi nhắc
lại Đó là tôi chẳng qua tôi thạo cái J
tôi thạo nhất Hồi đấy tôi nghiên cứu khá
nhiều kết hợp việc là giống như là bây
giờ tôi đang dùng chẳng hạn pp 7 hay là
larel 8 chẳng hạn nghĩa là tôi dạy cho
mấy ông về cách
A khi mà cài đặt một cái thư viện hoặc
là cách xử lý vấn đề thôi chứ không Thực
ra công ty ít áp dụng cái này giả sử là
đến cả Data Table nó cũng ít áp dụng
công ty tôi có áp dụng đâu đấy chẳng hạn
thế nên là mấy ông không cần phải nghiên
K quá sâu mấy cái đấy mấy ông chỉ cần
biết qua K tôi chỉ qua một vài cái thì
mấy ông thể tham khảo cho cái đồ án này
một cái Điển hình chẳng hạn hoặc
là về sau về sau kiểu tìm hiểu cái tương
tự là tìm
được xem xem cách tôi đ B như là thế gần
như là thế chứ không phải là kiểu dạng
bắt trước toàn bộ những cái gì Tôi áp
dụng thì mấy ông ôm hết về bởi vì mỗi
công ty nó còn một khác nữa đúng không ạ
Ờ nói chung là mấy ông không quan trọng
việc là mấy ông bây giờ mấy ông mà ngồi
chê p lỗi thời ha jig lỗi thời vân vân
vân thì mấy ông đang hiểu sai cái mục
đích tôi dạy rồi thế nhá
vẫn còn chưa liên hệ với các bạn cùng
nhóm đồ án ấy thì à thực ra là kể cả bây
giờ liên hệ được xong rồi Vài tuần nữa
các bạn đấy mà nghỉ có trường hợp đấy
bởi vì bây giờ các bạn còn chưa gặp nhau
mà các bạn chỉ nhắn tin nhau qua mạng
tôi còn chẳng biết được mặt mũi các bạn
hai chẳng ai cản được các bạn nghỉ cả có
rất nhiều lý do gi mà các bạn cũng không
phải học chính của tôi nữa các bạn còn
bậy đầy thứ cần học trên trưởng ch ạn
rất nhiều cái nói chung là
à các bạn bạn đấy thể mất tích bất cứ
lúc nào nên mấy ông cũng phải xác định
dần với việc là làm việc một mình hoặc
là làm việc theo nhóm gì gì đó Ờ đi làm
mấy ông sẽ thế đi đôi khi là mấy ông sẽ
không được chọn đồng nghiệp và đôi khi
đồng nghiệp cũng nghỉ hết thì ông không
nên nghỉ theo mấy ông nói chung là cái
đồ án này là cái thứ đánh giá năng lực
của mấy ông mấy ông a cứ cố gắng thậm
chế làm một mình cũng cũng phải dịu thôi
Hồi trước tôi làm một mình mà tôi còn
gánh những người khác nữa Nhưng chính vì
nhì thấy trình độ của tôi lại khá hơn
tôi nghĩa là mấy ông cứ xác định dần tin
tưởng này nhá chứ giờ mấy ông khóc vấy
rồi thì tôi cũng không biết là tôi khóc
lại với mấy ông ấy
ờ còn gì nữ nhở không biết tôi để mấy
cái này là cái gì
Ờ cách nào doanh nhân hoặc cá nhân tử
chấm điểm độ an toàn bảo mật hai phết
Nói chung là tôi từng chia sẻ cái cái
này vài lần rồi cooki cái page cooki hân
hoan này mấy hôm nay tôi còn xem lại
được những video cũ của Trang này đăng
về những hacker nữa Nói chung mấy ông tự
tra lại cái này thích ngồi đọc từ đầu
đến cuối Càng tốt Tôi cũng chưa thời
gian để ngồi đọc từ đầu đến cuối những
này đăng không Bởi vì thực ra nó có bài
nào cũng hay ấ nó có quá nhiều ý cũng
không thẩm không thấm được hết nhưng mà
Cái quan trọng là ông phải đọc lướt qua
để ông biết được là nó đã từng đăng v
cái gì để có gì về sau mình nhớ từ khoả
hóa mình tra lại từ trên chính cái page
này Điển hình như bây giờ này thì nó nó
là cái các chuyên gia thế giới đã tạo ra
một cái danh sách để mà kiểu à kiểu để
gọi là checklist để mà kiểu kiểu Dạ kiểu
tích vào cái nào đã mẩm mật cái nào
không Rồi tự đánh giá dướ ấ thì hoàn
toàn mình thể tự đánh giá được phần mềm
hệ thống của mình có đủ an toàn
rồi à ông đổa rồi đúng
đây thậm chí là
Ờ bạn thể quan sát được hơn 100.000
camera trên thế giới đấy có một trang
tên là in cam in insecurity nghĩa là
không không bảo mật ấy à Tổng hợp tất cả
camera trên thế giới tôi nhờ không lầm
Hình như là trong bình luận còn có cả à
một chuồng gà Việt Nam này có camera
nhưng không có nói chung là mật khẩu mặc
định hoặc là Thậm chí không mật khẩu nên
là cứ cắm mạng có thể vào
được một cái cam quay được hai cái cam
khác ở Việt
Nam tôi nhớ không lầm ở những cái góc
kiểu như này đôi khi có những vụ va chạm
bất ngờ nữa rất nhiều cái tấu hải nữa
ờ đại khá Thế Trang này đang rất nhiều
cái hay không bảo mật các thứ rất là hay
và cái này cũng để cảnh cảnh báo Mấy ông
nữa mấy ông có thể học công nghệ ông tin
lập trình nhưng mà hoàn toàn thể nên
biết về bảo mật nữa còn tốt
à cái tôi đ định nói là cái gì nhỉ Tôi
quên sử m à Đúng rồi ngoài việc là mấy
ông biết về cam này và biết được là bây
giờ chúng ta đang bị kiểu sống trong
thời đại công nghệ nó rất nhạy cảm đã
từng có kiểu một ông gần đây như có đăng
vụ là kiểu Trùm Mafia Vy kiểu tự nhiên
bị dính vào cái camera của của đi đường
gì gì đó xong rồi bị bắt bị FBI bắt
chẳng hạn rồi Trốn gần 10 năm rồi Sắp
được thoát rồi đấy xong bị bắt đấy nên
thành ra là kiểu Thời đại bây giờ nó
cũng kiểu rất là đáng sợ kiểu như thế về
công nghệ thông tin thậm chí là mấy ông
biết về bên Trung Quốc cái này không
biết động ha chính trị không như nhưng
mà Trung Quốc thì nó cũng có đánh giá à
con công dân ấy m có biết điểm tín dụng
công dân không social
dụng công
Trung Quốc xong rồi thường hay kiểu à
đấy social Credit ấy đấy nghe xong rồi
kiểu cứ muội xong Bây giờ bọn cứ chế
kiểu làm cái gì sai kiểu social Credit
bị trừ đấy Kiểu
thế gần đây nhất là kiểu liên quan đến
kiểu làm m cái tệ nạn kiểu à
thậm chí là mấy ông thuê game chơi ông
bị trừ điểm đấy nhá Đấy V chư xong rồi
cái đấy còn ảnh hưởng đến cả tiền thuế
này xong rồi việc đặt mua váy Tàu hay
mọi thứ các thứ ông sẽ bị chậm hơn hoặc
là nhanh hơn gì đó theo mức độ ánh giáng
của ông thì cái
đấy Đúng rồi rất nhiều ông bình luận
kiểu tao mà sống ở đây chắc tao
âm đáy xã hội V đấy thì
cái đấy Thực ra là cái đấy thì là nó áp
dụng cũng cũng lâu
rồi nhưng mà nhưng mà nó cũng có cái
hiệu quả riêng con người chúng con người
ở bên đây vẫn sống được mà đúng không
vẫn có và và ông thấy ấy nó vẫn đang là
cưng Quốc nên thành ra tôi nghĩ là nó
vẫn có cái hay của nó nhưng nhược điểm
là sống nó hơi bị áp lực tí nên về cơ
bản tôi vẫn thấy Việt Nam Đúng là Thiên
được rất nhiều cái Thiên được đấy
nói đấy không phải chân biến nhều nhá
Đấy thiên đường thật đấy ông bây giờ có
thể phóng xe đi ngược chiều các thứ cũng
lắm là bị ăn chụi đấy Kiểu như thế bên
nước ngoài hề không tù hoặc kiểu phạt
nghìn nghìn
cái này cũng là một cái có nhắc đến ở
trong cái
À cái gọi phim truyền hình mà tôi nghĩ
là mấy ông nên xem nó tên là đây mấy ông
thử đoán tên đấy tên của phim truyề hình
ấy là gì gọi là TV show à TV show Đúng
rồi phim truyền hình phim truyền hình mà
có nhắc đến kiểu về cái điểm tín dụng
công dân đấy C thế kết hợp V có cả có
một tập khác thì nó nói về kiểu mắt mình
bản chất nó là camera quay lại thu lại
mọi thứ rất nhiều cái nó nói về công
nghệ tương lai th hiện đại sẽ như th nào
Vân v Vân Vân nó nó cả mặt ưu và mặt
Nhược đấy có ông nào biết được cái tên
của cái truyền hình ha
đây đ Đúng rồi nhưng mà nó bắt đầu ằng
chữ
nhiều đấy cho tôi T cả bên SQL mà không
xem đúng không
biết đúng không cái đấy tên là black
miror black
Ờ nếu Dịch Ra Ở bên trên phim mới phim
moi thì sẽ là là mặt tối C mệ cái này
rất là hay TV Series kiểu phim chuyền
hình và mỗi tập thì sẽ tầm 50 phút Đúng
rồi Hương đen dịch thô Ờ thì cái cái này
nó sẽ lúc đầu nó sẽ luôn là những cái
điểm sáng điểm tốt khi mà nó nói về
tương lai khi mà kiểu
nó nó kiểu dạng khi mà tương lai mình có
mình có robot chẳng hạn hay mình có cái
gì gì đó chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ có những
điểm lợi như th nào nó sẽ nhược điểm như
nào nói là nhược điểm không hẳn đúng lắm
Bởi vì có những cái kết phim của hậu
nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là mấy ông nếu mà ông
nào mà
không Không chịu được nổi nhiệt thì nên
bỏ qua tập đầu của phần 1 Nói chung là
tập các tập nó khác nó cũng chả liên
quan đến nhau cả nên là chứ nếu mà ông
xem Phần một Đặc biệt à tập Đầu phần một
kết hợp về con
gái Xem cảnh 18+ rồi kết hợp với cả liên
quan đến cả bắt nạt các thứ thứ thứ thì
tôi nghĩ là ông sẽ không không không dám
xem tập tập sau cho tập sau nó chẳng
liên quan gì cả đấy như mấy ông có thể
cân nhắc cái này có nhiều cái hay phết
Nó cũng có một cái đề cập có một tập đề
cập đến cái điểm tín dụng kia nó khiến
cho con người ta sống như th nào đấy kết
hợp việc là như tôi và bạn cũng có một
tập tập nói về vi con mắt mình lưu lại
quay video lưu lại rất nhiều cái nó sẽ
có kỷ niệm đẹp và kỷ niệm xấu vân vân
vân đấy rất nhiều Nói chung là à ông Khi
mà xem thấy đôi khi là mấy ông xem những
cái phim Liên Quan Đế khoa học viễn
tưởng thế mấy ông lại càng hình dung ra
những cái ý tưởng gì gì đó để mấy ông
làm tôi hồi trước tôi nghĩ thế Cái khoa
học viễn tưởng nó sinh ra là như thế
khoa học sinh khoa học viễn tưởng sinh
ra để kích thích cái sự sáng tạo con
người à Con người chúng ta thể làm những
cái gì và đúng là có rất nhiều cái mình
đã từng phát minh ra dựa theo khoa học
viễn tưởng mình làm được rồi đúng không
ạ nên là tôi nghĩ là cái đấy là một cái
hay em mớ không xem
Ờ cái đấy liên quan công nghệ
mà
Ờ trả lời thêm câu
là C này liên quan đến code một tí nh
được Nói chung là đại khái là khi Mình
lưu mình xin Tức là đồng bộ dữ liệu từ
bên database này sang database kia thì
tôi không dùng cái kiểu một cái tool gì
cả mà tôi sẽ dùng code trong larel n có
hỗ trợ là kiểu chạy chạy kiểu cứ một
tiếng một lần hay là 5 phút một lần
chẳng hạn để mà chạy đồng bộ dữ liệu
sang thôi về sau tôi sẽ chỉ mấy ông V vụ
vụ CR job này sao
ờ khi anh làm đồ án ra trường thì anh
làm dựa theo đồ án người khác hay là một
đ đoán riêng biệt Tôi không biết mấy ông
thế nào nhưng hồi trước hồi trước mấy
ông biết tôi định làm một cái dự án gì
tôi không biết là bây giờ có phân mềm
chưa chắc là có rồi bởi vì chúng ta đôi
khi nghĩ ra ý tưởng là Dựa theo nhu cầu
chúng ta và chắc chắn là không phải nhu
cầu một mình mình là như thế có thể trừ
khi ông lập dị quá còn không thì rất
nhiều người từng nghĩ đến Và thậm chí là
đã từng có người làm rồi Hoặc là giống
như là nhiều ông bảo là kiểu gì cũng sẽ
có một ông Ấn ởo đó trên thế giới giỏi
hơn ông Và thậm chí làm rồi
đấy
thì thì cái hồi trước tôi đã từng nghĩ
cái ý tưởng tôi làm đồ án cái đồ án nâng
cao ấy Ờ nhưng mà thầy tôi không duyệt
đó là cái ý tưởng đó là ví dụ Giả sử Bây
giờ ông có một đống nhóm bạn chẳng hạn
Ờ xong rồi muốn học lớp kiểu kể đấy muốn
chọn một ngày đi cà phê chẳng hạn đấy
mỗi thằng một lịch thành ra kiểu rất khó
để mà sắp xếp các thứ thứ đúng không ạ
Mấy ông ngồi chát mồm Chắc ngồi cạnh
nhau cả buổi kết hợp việc là
ờ kiểu Nói chung mỗi thằng một lịch ấy n
hồi đy tôi làm định làm là kiểu Ờ tạo
một cái link xong rồi tất cả cùng điện
vào Điền những cái lúc mà Mình bận trong
một tuần hay một tháng gì gì đó nó sẽ đề
xuất ra chế giả đề xuất 10 buổi gần nhất
lý tưởng để tất cả cùng dành đấy khá thế
Nó rất là đơn giản nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là
có khi ở phần mềm có rồi Hoặc là mình
chưa biết đến gì gì đó nhưng bây giờ Ông
mấy ông công nhận không Bây giờ ông có
tầm năm đứa bạn thôi chẳng hạn mấy ông
rủ đi cà phê mà có những thằng nó làm
kiểu giờ em kiểu thế cuối tuần nó mới
làm chẳng
hạn sẽ nói chung là cũng mất thời gian
đấy nhưng mà thậm chí là có phần mềm gần
đây anh Tuấn giới thiệu còn hay hơn tôi
như tôi ch chia sẻ mấy ông rồi nó là
meet in the m đồ à hình như là gần cuối
cha cái này nó bị sao về
Ờ mid in the
midle tách m
tôi tra cái miễn phí cơ Nói chung là đại
khái là mấy ông tra trên Google dịch
xong rồi Kiểu nó sẽ à nhem Google Map
xong rồi ở Việt Nam mà thi xong rồi nó
sẽ kiểu đề xuất ra là chúng ta thể gặp
nhau đoạn giữa giữa này rất phù hợp cho
tận ba bốn người cùng kiểu muốn có buồn
cả buổi cà phê ở đó xong kiểu muốn cố
tìm đoạn giữa của tất cả đấy rất hợp lý
Tìm hàng ăn hai hàng cà phê xung quanh
rất là tiện đúng không ạ nhưng mà hình
Tôi nhớ lần cuối Tôi lên cái Trang đấy
thì nó bị bởi vì dùng cái api Google Map
ấy thì nó cũng có một cái giới hạn nhất
định thôi nó về sau nó thu phí mà Bởi vì
cái trang này miễn phí Hình như trang
đấy nó cũng bay rồi vậy phần cuối tô vào
nó đang bị nó đang bị giới hạn rồi chắc
bây giờ bay rồi nhưng đây phần mềm này
có Hàn phần mềm này T không biết là cái
này như nào chắc cũng tương tự thôi
nhưng đại khái như thế nghĩa là có những
phần mềm sinh ra kiểu với mục đích của
ông à Ông có nhu cầu gì kiểu gì cũng sẽ
có một cái vài phần mềm nó có thể thỏa
mãn nhu cầu ấy rồi đấy
à Mấy ông cũng không phải vì thế mà Mấy
ông sẽ kiểu không làm nó nữa mấy ông vẫn
có thể làm mà nó tiện hơn nó thể nói
tiếng Việt thô nó tiện hơn kiểu phù hợp
cho mình cái này nó chưa đủ tiện chẳng
hạn chưa đủ ý Ông chẳng hạn nhiều mà ý
tưởng gi nhiều lắm Ông cứ nghĩ r ông làm
xong ông sẽ phân tích bài toán để mà ông
ông tự cải thiện thêm trình độ bản thân
có nghĩa là hoàn toàn
người lạ bây giờ công nhận phổ biến ông
có thể tìm hiểu về kiểu retime để chat
theo thời gian thực Hoặc là ông dùng bên
thứ ba là có nhề con chatbot kiểu chat
Fi ấ ấ nó sẽ tự động kiểu kết nối người
lạ Hổ ông thử thứ cần đây có hẳn những
cái fanpage hồi trước hồi trước rầm rộ
cả vụ mấy cái chat fanpage conf
confection ấy xong rồi nó cũng sẽ Nó sử
dụng con chatbot bên thứ ba đấy để kết
nối người lại rồi Hai thằng thường nhắn
tin nhau
đâyi cùng toàn đực với nhau hoặc là hoặc
là đực giẻ gái lừa nhau hoặc là hai đứa
con gái rồi cứ nghĩ nhau là được n
[âm nhạc]
thứ Hồi đấy tôi nhớ là còn thêm cả bọn
nó còn hỏi nhau một câu để biết được xem
có phải trai gái mà thực ra đến bây giờ
tôi cũng không biết câu hỏi à Không biết
câu trả lời đó là cái này hơi tế nhị một
tí các bạn nữ tạm tắt tắt tiếng đi nhá
đó là ờ trong trong
a trong cái gói băng vệ sinh thì có bao
nhiêu
tôi cũng không biết câu trả
cái đấy đi Đúng không Đúng không hỏi thế
x biết được
nó ghi ngay bên vỏ ngoài nhưng mà Mấy
ông có bao giờ để ý không đúng
nữa cì ừ
nhở post thì tôi cũng có dùng hàm khó
kiểu connected con x 3 nh mình Mình còn
chẳng biết cái có cái hàm đấy đấy bqu
đúng không ý ông kia bqu đúng không
chịu mình n quá mới với tôi may thế mình
cũng dùng pod nhưng mà mà chỉ ở mức làm
thống kê cũng chưa biết về mấy cái
chung là mấy cái này nó sâu hơn sâu cũng
sâu phết nhưng mà sâu này s của pp có
thôi với cái thằng khác có thể không có
gì gì đó tôi không rõ vụ đấy
lắm nhưng mà Đúng là về sau muốn tối ưu
thì chắc là phải nghiên cứu sâu hơn cái
này tôi khẳng Thế là tôi mới khẳng định
là tôi bên A công ty tôi chỉ nắm chắc về
sub này vài cái vài cái gọi các thứ còn
để nâng cao hơn thì chắc là vẫn phải
nghiên cứu thêm Ừ chắc là tôi sẽ phải
đọc thêm nhiều tài liệu nữa Mình phải
đọc nhiều lắm mà chính vì đọc nhiều tài
liệu thì nó cũng hơi bị khô khan m không
hiểu không Không phải thấm được ngày 1
ngày hai
được ok à Mấy ông chắc là cũng không còn
thắc mắc hỏi Hàn gì nhở chắc buổi hôm
nay chỉ kết thúc tạm đấy thôi nhớ nhá À
tôi xin phép thứ thứ năm thứ bảy nhì nhá
Có gì là tôi sẽ Ờ bù tôi sẽ bù vào buổi
sau à tuần gi tuàn giàu được không ạ
buổi hôm nay tạm thế
đã chào mấy ông nhá